♪♪
-Is this thing busted
or something?
It's taking forever.
-Girl, I know Biden
better do something
about these gas prices.
-I know, right?
$6 a gallon?
What are they using, Casamigos?
[ Both laugh ]
-Excuse me.
You know, I ain't trying
to bother y'all,
but y'all looking very beautiful
tonight.
-Oh, boy.
-Here we go.
-I just want to know if I can
get your number or something.
You know what I'm saying?
-No.
-Damn, saying no, can't I at
least talk to you for a second?
You know what I'm saying?
-Uh, you got a hole
in your jacket.
-So what, though?
What, you got a man,
or something like that?
-Yep.
-I'm married.
-So what, though?
That mean I can't get
to know you?
-You got bags on your feet.
-So what, though?
That mean I can't talk to you?
-Talk about what?
-Do you work here or something?
-No, I ain't got no job.
But I get money, though.
-By collecting cans?
-Don't worry about all that.
I'm saying, girl, can I get
your phone number or something?
-I think your car is on fire.
-What's that even mean?
-She means your car is literally
on fire right now.
-So what, though?
I'm just saying, baby,
I can't know your name?
-Is that your baby?
-Is what my baby?
-The baby in the stroller
rolling into the street.
[ Horn honking ]
-Yeah, I guess that's my baby.
Why y'all can't
answer my questions, though?
That's what I want to know.
-Oh, my God,
what is your question?
-I'm saying, can I have
your home address?
-No!
-Ooh!
What do we have here?
-Oh, God.
Would this pump hurry up? Damn.
-Do my eyes deceive me,
or am I looking at
my future ex-baby mama?
-"Ex-baby mama"?
And how would that happen?
-I'm saying, though,
what's your name, baby girl?
-Dude, are you
peeing on yourself right now?
-Look, man, I'm just trying
to get to know you, baby girl.
-This my homie.
We're not trying to bother
y'all.
-Yeah, we just want to know
your sign.
Are you a Virgo
or a "Sagittaricruz"?
-What happened to your teeth?
-My what?
-Are you wearing
a hospital gown?
-I might be.
You going to nurse me?
-Ooh!
-Oh, my God, why is this pump
taking so long?
-Girl, when are you going to let
me take you out
to Harry Potter World
and drink some butterbeer?
-Ew!
-Do you know a bird just
[bleep] on your head?
-Don't worry 'bout all that,
girl.
-Yo, she got jokes!
-I know, right?
-Is that a tail?
-It might be!
-A tail?!
-I'm trying to take you camping.
-Exactly, my man
just trying to take you --
-Oh, my God!
Your friend just got hit
by a car.
-Don't worry about all that.
I can't get a hug, though?
-Okay, girl, let's just get
out of here.
-Yep.
[ Engine starts ]
-[ Groans ]
-Man, they was ugly, anyway.
Let's get out of here, man.
-They was busted!